unglaublich aber leben kann offenbar im
vakuum des weltraums existieren 533 tage
lang haben mikroorganismen in einem
experiment kasten an der außenseite der
iss der internationalen raumstation
verbracht das ergebnis ist überraschend
denn die organismen trotzdem nicht nur
intensive uv-strahlung sondern auch dem
vakuum des weltraums und extremen
temperaturschwankungen alle wichtigen
infos zu diesem spektakulären experiment
an bord daher ist es jetzt fix zum
science fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasste nichts herzlich
willkommen jetzt steht es fest die
organismen und biomoleküle des
sogenannten bio max projekts haben den
18 monate lang stresstest im all
bestanden und sind als überlebende zur
erde zurückgekehrt das projekt biology
and mars experiment kurz bei max wird
koordiniert vom deutschen zentrum für
luft und raumfahrt mehrere hundert
proben von organismen wurden dafür
zwischen 2014 und 2016 an bord der
internationalen raumstation iss den
bedingungen von mars und weltraum
ausgesetzt die forschungsteams von
bromex wollen damit unter anderem
herausfinden ob organismen von der erde
auch auf dem mars überleben können also
ob es auch auf dem mars leben geben kann
denn fest steht der rote planet hat
einige eigenschaften mit der erde
gemeinsam die grundvoraussetzung für
leben wie beispielsweise die atmosphäre
des planeten und die existenz
lebenswichtiger elemente wie wasserstoff
kohlenstoff sauerstoff und schwefel sind
vorhanden
doch klar ist auch dass die bedingungen
auf dem wüstenplaneten heutzutage sehr
extrem sind der mars ist sehr trocken
und kalt extreme bedingungen also denen
die organismen auf dem roten planeten
trotzen müssten können also
mikroorganismen dennoch den mars bewohnt
sind organismen in der lage die
bedingungen im weltraum zu überleben so
dass ein transport zwischen planeten wie
der erde und dem mars denkbar wäre die
sogenannte space com hypothese oder auf
deutsch spanisch per me hypothese der
zufolge kamen das irdische leben vor
langer zeit aus dem weltall das
verständnis hier
es gibt mikro aus
organismen die als spermien fungieren
und planeten wie die erde befruchten
eine weitere wesentliche frage stellung
des bio max experiments lautet wie
stabil erweisen sich biologische
moleküle unter weltraum und
raumbedingungen das forschungsteam
wählte dementsprechend vor allem
organismen als probanden aus die auch
auf der erde unter extremen
umweltbedingungen überleben können
in der fachsprache werden sie als
extremo viel bezeichnet also extreme
umgebungen liebend in den proben
befanden sich beispielsweise pilze
flechten algen und sogenannte uhr
bakterien dazu jean pierre paul de vera
einer der beteiligten astrobiologen wir
haben unter anderem maschinen also
einzellige mikroorganismen wie sie auf
der erde seit über dreieinhalb
milliarden jahren im salzigen meerwasser
gibt untersucht unsere probanden sind
verwandte die aus dem permafrost der
arktis isoliert worden
sie haben unter weltraumbedingungen
überlebt und sind zudem mit unseren
instrumenten delektiert solche einzeller
wären kandidaten für lebensformen die
wir uns auch auf dem mars vorstellen
könnten
der experiment kasten mit den primitiven
irdische organismen wurde im sommer 2014
von zwei russischen kosmonauten auf der
außenplattform der iss installiert die
organismen waren in den proben behältern
in simulierten mineralischen maß böden
und imitierter marsatmosphäre
eingebettet im herbst 2014 wurde dann
die schutzabdeckung entfernt und die
proben waren unter hochtransparente
gläsern den grenzwertigen
weltraumbedingungen ausgesetzt und zwar
bis zum februar 2016 dann wurde das
experiment zunächst wieder in die
raumstation zurückgeholt dann gelangten
die proben an bord der sojus raumkapsel
wieder zur erde zurück mehr als 30
forschungseinrichtungen in zwölf ländern
waren seitdem damit beschäftigt die
proben zu analysieren hier ging es vor
allem um die stabilität vom
zellstrukturen und ob diese nach einem
langen aufenthalt im weltall immer noch
mit bestimmten instrumenten erkennbar
sind doch dass sich die mikroorganismen
so resistent zeigten ist nur eines der
zahlreichen erkenntnisse die das bei max
experiment ermöglicht hat denn zudem
wurden auch die aktionsmöglichkeiten
entwickelt mit dem mikroorganismen und
diese gebildeten stoffwechselprodukte
sehr viel einfacher aufgespürt werden
können als bislang
die sprache ist hier beispielsweise von
der sogenannten raman spektroskopie ein
großer fortschritt bei der suche nach
leben auf dem mars dazu ute böttcher vom
berliner dlr-institut für optische
sensorsysteme mit der
raman-spektroskopie können wir
zerstörungs und berührungsfrei proben
auf der marsoberfläche von einem rover
aus untersuchen laserstrahlen also
energiereiches gebündeltes nicht regen
moleküle zu schwingungen an
unterschiedliche moleküle haben dabei
unterschiedliche stimmungen mutter die
wie ein unverwechselbarer fingerabdruck
zur identifikation von molekülen und
kristallstrukturen verwendet werden
können
von diesen ganzen erkenntnissen werden
zukünftige missionen wie etwa die
geplante exomars mission der esa
ungeheuer profitieren zusammen mit dem
russischen partner roskosmos soll hier
ein rover auf dem roten planeten gezielt
nach spuren von leben forschen die
ergebnisse von bio max werden in einer
datenbank archiviert die als grundlage
für die suche nach leben in unserem
sonnensystem dient die aktuellen
erkenntnisse können somit also erheblich
zur identifikation und zuordnung der
signale beitragen die der esa rover
registriert damit unterstützen die
ergebnisse des dmx experiments die space
beim theorie dieser hat schon sehr
langer zeit heftig diskutiert wird und
beschreibt wie das leben vor 3,8
milliarden jahren auf die erde gelangt
sein könnte der theorie zufolge
existieren auf dem frühen maß organismen
durch an hast du jeden anschlag wurde
gestein weggeschleudert und mit ihm auch
die organismen ins innere des
sonnensystems manche dieser
gesteinsbrocken könnten demnach als
meteoriten mit unserer erde
zusammengeprallt sein wo sich die
mikroorganismen dann angesiedelt und
weiterentwickelt haben demnach kam das
leben also aus dem weltall auf die erde
die ergebnisse des bayer max projekts
jedenfalls sprechen für diese these
andere frage wem gehört der mond können
wir dort grundstücke kaufen anklicken
also hier ansehen und weltraum wissen
von astro comics tv abonnieren oder
kanal bis dann bleibt dran